since her discovery baby lubicz frozen
remains have traveled across four time
zones and everyone hopes she's arrived
intact
she has been carefully maintained below
freezing to prevent potential decay or
bacterial invasion and she's been sealed
in a vacuum packed plastic bag to keep
her tissue hydrated for easier study
in good shape
the scientists are relieved to see that
they're careful preparations have paid
off
her trunk is in good condition it's good
that nothing's nothing's happened in
transit day
if we lose too much water it will be
harder to study
good resolution of x-ray images is more
difficult on dry tissue for this scam
the team uses a thin wooden capsule to
keep Newberg cold
dr. Suzuki scanner enables him to
identify the precise location of lioba's
internal organs the aim is to create an
anatomical map of lubicz insights the
map shows scientists were to look in an
eventual autopsy while minimizing damage
to her body with this data dr. Suzuki
will produce two-dimensional
cross-sectional images from trunk to
tail and ultimately recreate lubicz
entire body in 3d here we go we can pull
the tail oh you can see all the
mineralisation memorization inside the
bones at distance this is the deliver
yes
mmm
it's hard okay and coming to the neck
until now no one really knew the state
of lubicz internal organs lamellae
because we see them in a stack sort of
moving by
every everyone is perfect
well that's very promising three days
from now
the team will reveal the first new
images inside this extinct woolly
mammoth while in Siberia the inside
story of lioba's discovery unfolds